let's do one more radical equation
example and we'll make this one a
slightly a slightly hairy one so let's
say we have the principal square root of
10 minus 5x plus plus the principal
square root of 1 minus X is equal to 7
now just like I've said over the last
two videos your goal is always to
isolate one of the radicals and then
square both sides of the equation so we
can isolate this one right here by let's
subtract this radical from both sides of
this equation so you get minus the
square root of 1 minus X minus the
square root of 1 minus X the left-hand
side these cancel out the left-hand side
you're just left with the square root of
10 minus 5x is equal to on the right
hand side you have 7 7 minus the square
root of 1 minus X all ideas corrected
this from both sides essentially moving
it over to the right hand side now we've
isolated one of the radicals let's
square both sides of this equation so
this squared 10 minus 5x squared is just
going to be or the square root of 10
minus 5x squared so if I square that
that's just going to be equal to 10
minus 5x and this is going to be equal
to this expression squared now this
might look a little daunting but you
just have to remember you just have to
remember that a plus B squared is equal
to a squared plus 2 a B plus B squared
in fact you don't have to remember it
you could actually multiply it out if
you ever forget this now this is just
the same situation where a is a 7 and
our B is negative the square root of 1
minus X so if we expand this out or
multiply this out this is going to be 7
squared it's going to be 7 squared which
is 49 and then plus 2 times 7 times this
so this is a negative right here so it's
going to be minus 2 times 7 let me write
well.alright
times 7 times the square root
root of 1 minus X we got the negative
sign from that negative sign the 7 is
over there 1 minus square root of 1
minus X is there 2 times it when you
take a perfect square that just ends up
when you actually take the product and
then finally Plus this guy squared this
guy over here squared now the negative
part negative 1 squared that's just
becomes positive square root of 1 minus
x squared is just going to be 1 minus X
and let's simplify this so this is going
to be equal to 10 minus 5x is equal to
well one thing we can do let's add the
49 and the 1 so you add the 49 and the 1
you get 50 50 and then minus this is 2
times 7 is 14 times the square root of 1
minus X and then we have this final
minus X out here minus X now let's see
what else we can do here we can subtract
10 from both sides of this equation I
don't want to do too many steps at once
cuz I don't want to this is a slightly
involved problem so if you subtract 10
from both sides you get negative 5x is
equal to 40 minus 14 times the square
root of 1 minus X minus X and then we
can add X to both sides essentially
getting rid of that character over there
so if you add X to both sides of this
equation
the left-hand side becomes negative 4x
and the right-hand side this guy
disappears and you're just left with 40
minus 14 times the square root of 1
minus X and now let's subtract 40 from
both sides I'm just trying to isolate
this expression right here so let's
subtract 40 from both sides we get
negative 4x minus 40 is equal to
negative 14 times the square root of 1
minus X just subtracted this from both
sides so it disappeared on the right
shows up a negative form on the left now
we could square both sides but we let's
simplify a little bit let's divide both
sides by negative
- that'll get rid of all of these
negative numbers and make the numbers a
little bit smaller so you divide
everything by negative 2 we get 2x we
switch colors we get 2x plus 20 is equal
to 7 times the square root of 1 minus X
just divided everything by negative 240
divided by negative 2 is 20 14 divided
by negative 2 is positive 7
now we could divide by 7 but that makes
things awkward we've essentially
isolated the radical we're scaling it by
a little bit but we can if we square
both sides of this equation that radical
will disappear so let's square both
sides of that equation let's square both
sides the left-hand side becomes 4x
squared plus 2x times 20 is 4 40 x times
2 is 80 X plus 400 is going to be equal
to 7 squared which is 49 times this
expression squared well the square root
of 1 minus x squared is just going to be
1 minus 1 minus X now let me let me well
let's just keep going down here I have
space down here I could just keep going
so what can we do here let me I don't
want to skip too many steps so 4x
squared plus 80 X plus 400 is equal to
distribute the 49 49 minus 49 X and now
let's see we could add 49 X to both
sides of this equation actually let's do
this let's add 49 X to both sides so
we're going to add 49 X to both sides
and let's subtract 49 let's subtract 49
from both sides of the equation and we
are left with the left hand side becomes
4 x squared now 80 plus 49 80 plus 49 is
80 plus 40 is 120 so it's going to be
plus 129 X and then 400 - 49 is 351 plus
351 is equal to these guys cancel out
those guys cancel out is equal to 0 now
let me just make sure that I haven't
made some crazy mistake because these
are strange-looking numbers 80 plus 49
yep that's right 129 400 minus 49 that's
351 now we have just a straight-up
quadratic equation let's use the
quadratic formula since we have all
these crazy numbers so our solutions
we're going to get X is equal to
negative B so it's negative 129 plus or
minus plus or minus the square root the
square root of 129 squared
129 squared minus 4 times a which is 4
times C which is 351 definitely gonna
need a calculator for this one all of
that over 2 times a which is 2 times 4
which is 8 let's get our calculator out
to actually calculate this so let's
figure out the discriminant first so we
have 129 squared minus we're going to
say sixteen times 351 16 times 351 oh
that's not what I wanted to do whoops
16 times 351 four times four is 16 times
351 is that crazy number let's take the
square root of it take the square root
and on this calculator press second for
a second and answer right here that'll
use the last answer so it's going to
take the square root of that right there
it's 105 so lucky for us it's not that
crazy of a number so we get X is equal
to negative 129 plus or minus 105 over 8
let's just use the calculator for this
so the first one if we have negative 129
plus 105 plus 105
what do we get negative 24 then you
divide that by 8 that's going to be
negative 3 so one of our answers is
negative 3 now what happens if we take
negative 129 minus 105 minus 105 we get
negative 234 divide that by 8 divide
that by 8 we get negative 29 point 2 5
so our two answers are negative 3 and
negative 29 point 2 5 so X is equal to
negative 3 and x is equal to negative 29
point 2 5
now remember this is a radical equation
we have to validate that both of these
work or if they don't work what they're
going to be extraneous solutions or one
of them might be an extraneous solution
so let's copy these and go back up to
our original problem up here right there
let me paste them so we remember what
our solutions were and let's let's just
evaluate them in the calculator to see
if they work to see if they work I don't
want to use that calculator use this
calculator much better all right so
let's try negative 3 so we're going to
take the square root of 10 minus 5 times
negative 3 that's that right there we
got out of the radical plus the square
root of 1 minus negative 3 1 minus
negative 3 I'm doing nothing in my head
obviously that would be positive 3 and
all of that what is that going to be
equal to it's equal to 7 so negative 3
definitely works now let's try negative
29 point two five see what happens so we
take once again the square root of 10
minus 5 times negative 29 point two five
right close parenthesis plus the square
root of
one minus negative twenty nine point two
five is equal to eighteen this didn't
work it's not even equal to negative
seven that's because we took negative
squared we took the squared principle
square roots twice or we square it twice
oh we lost information twice but the
simple answer is this does not work it
is a extraneous solution we got that
solution assuming not the principal
roots assuming the negative square roots
somewhere along here so for this
equation that deals with just the
principal roots we can say that this
right here is an extraneous solution
extraneous and the only valid solution
to this equation is X is equal to
negative three